[Applause]
[Music]
happy wednesday america it's great to
see all of you and i'm sure it's
likewise
it must be hard to concentrate on the
valuable insights delivered each night
here when you're distracted by the
handsomeness of the messenger
it must be like trying to read a book at
a nude beach
in sweden
sometimes i wish i was homely
so people would take me seriously
it's the edge that other people have
over me
so
the news industry is like san francisco
after taco night
it's in deep doo-doo
anyway according to axios the news site
not the greek personal trainer who stole
my amex card
engagement with news content is
plummeting like brian stelter skydiving
with a malfunctioning rip cord
they blame it on the public being tired
of the constant barrage of bad headlines
but like shannon bream's little goody
two-shoes routine i don't buy that for a
second
axios claims cable viewership is down 19
in prime time in the first half of the
year for cnn msnbc and fox news i told
fox jesse would have that effect but
they didn't listen
it sucks until you actually read further
and i quote
those losses skew heavily towards cnn
and msnbc
wait wait i'm not done which are down 47
and 33 respectively
fox ratings are up 12 percent
yeah
but what the hell what the hell
why did you group them together and say
they all went down on average
when only two did that's like lumping
michael jordan in with the buffalo bills
and the french army
they also claimed that cable news saw a
drop compared to pre-pandemic levels
with again three networks down 15 in
prime time until
they then say msnbc and cnn are down 16
and 35 respectively
and fox is up
so again why
don't lump us in with andrea mitchell
unless i also get to sleep with alan
greenspan
i hear he's an animal
but it's no surprise they pull this crap
and it's also no surprise to see cnn and
msnbc go down as we rise they suck and
we don't
that should be our new slogan
let's compare here's cnn
if you're not going to get vaccinated
you don't want a social distance you
don't want to wear a mask then maybe you
don't want to go to the hospital when
you get sick looking ahead to 2020
one reason why i'm taking you seriously
as a contender is because of your
presence on cable news oh the crunch
you have a wing hanging out of my mouth
you were on a zoom call with your
colleagues everyone took a break for
several minutes during which time you
were caught masturbating on camera oh my
god
classic
that's cnn but here's spock's
[Music]
yeah
but uh here's msnbc
when a petulant and not so bright
billionaire casually bought one of the
world's most influential messaging
machines
and just handed it to the far right you
got to stop complaining when there's so
many people who literally the inflation
rate means they may only have two meals
instead of three and yeah it's costing
you more for gas but guess what you're
still going to take that holiday we are
essentially slaves to a document
that was written you know more than 230
years ago by a tiny group of white
slave-owning men
no
that's msnbc again here's fox
[Music]
so you know it's pretty obvious why
they're in trouble but axios blames
exhaustion but is the exhaustion over
bad news or fake news because if it were
bad news then it would hit us all
equally
so it's really about fakeness and how it
only flows from one direction and that
can only be why people are sick of them
but they're not sick of us
it's like saying people aren't eating as
much pizza because they're sick of it
but when you look closer it's frozen
pizza not papa john's or dominos
better get free pizza out of that so
they're not sick of pizza they're sick
of bad pizza
so in the media what exactly is this bad
pizza
[Music]
you've been hoaxed
[Music]
yeah it's it's time
i almost threw up it's time to list all
the major hoaxes that makes us hate the
news well not all of them since this
show is only an hour long or actually 42
minutes minus ads on buying gold
and close-ups of sebastian gorka
of course there's russian collusion the
steele dossier trump calling nazis fine
people the russians paying bounties on
american soldiers trump telling people
to drink bleach trump overfed koi fish
in japan
trump cleared protesters with tear gas
the border patrol agents whipping
illegals hunter's laptop was rushing to
info
i need to breathe hold on
okay where was i oh yeah crt is a hoax
january 6 was worse than 9 11. men can
get pregnant which i know is total bs
because i've been trying for years
[Laughter]
i don't have the hips
inflation is all putin's fault and of
course bradley cooper is dating huma
abedin yeah and i'm dating anthony
weiner
so it's not that we're sick of being
told dark truths is that we're being
lied to by stupid people who think we're
stupid today most news outlets are just
high-tech versions of supermarket
tabloids the ones with headlines like
amazing rooster cries rocks that cure
cancer
axios also claims that the interest in
the president went down a lot under
biden they also claimed that after trump
took office he generated seven times
more google searches than obama but
maybe that's because american presidents
are more interesting if they're born
here
an unhitched conspiracy frequency
i said that for shannon
could it be that trump was more
interesting perhaps but the glut of
anti-trump stories which revealed later
as fake created a lot of the interest
and the stories were all bad they were
never good not once was there a fake
story about trump refusing to get peed
on by a hooker
so you see how axios undermines its own
point it's bad news that got clicks but
now they stop those hoaxes
the press refuses to paint their boy in
that light so they'll just settle for
bad numbers and call it exhaustion
so it wasn't the public that lost
interest it was the media who
deliberately lost interest in doing an
honest day's work instead the hoaxes now
protect those in power hoax is like the
adults are back in charge hey joe's a
moderate
no joe had no idea what hunter was up to
no joe's not corrupt and he's definitely
not senile and joe can do 200 one-arm
push-ups
and get this his wife is a doctor
a medical doctor
lover
anyway
so they claim we're tired of bad news no
we just got tired of the lies the
blinders are now off and we see the
industry for what it is it's a conveyor
belt of misinformation a sausage factory
turning out sausage that tastes like
styrofoam soaked in cat urine with a
hint of fennel
getting hungry they're paid liars like
the refs for the harlem globetrotters
it's amazing how we went from walter
cronkite to cliff clavin
from reporting facts to telling tall
tales or maybe it's always been cliff
clavin and we really never knew
but it's different here at fox we don't
hoax you we just want to have a good
time and you can't do that without trust
and at gutfeld
trust is our safe word
[Laughter]
although i do have a habit of ignoring
those
[Applause]
yes welcome tonight's guest
she's so sweet that sugar center hate
mail host of fox news and night evil
shannon brewer
i'd like to keep him overnight for
observation safe word
host of dr drew after dark it's dr drew
she stays slim the old-fashioned way
diet and tuberculosis
fox news contributor tattoo
[Music]
and
he once gave the shirt off his back to
cover the field during a rain delay my
master's sidekick in the nwa world
television
esb
esb is in the house huh yes that's right
and it is the number one question i get
when i'm outside of fox is why you how
did you get this evil nickname they want
to know the truth but of course i can
you should just respond with now you're
going to find out
and then they just black out dab them in
the eye with a pencil
so why do you think people are sick of
the other guys but they're not sick of
us first of all i'm surprised that they
included the good fox numbers in there
like you know they didn't want to write
this article including all that positive
stuff for us your show's definitely not
suffering and the show after your show
also not suffering yes leading the way
i honestly feel like the people who
watch the other outlets they're often
going to be fans of the left fans of the
democrats fans of the president and he's
having such a rough time the poll
numbers are terrible starting from
afghanistan and the the disastrous
withdrawal that cost us 13 additional
lives there from our brave men and women
all the way through now it's been one
scandal after another i don't think it's
fun for them to watch it's not like when
they had president trump as a punching
bag now their guy is there um and
there's not good news on him yeah trump
was a lot of fun even when they were
trashing him it was fun to watch when
you didn't even agree with it because he
always fought back you know we've talked
about this dr drew at length sometimes
on tv sometimes privately in my my uh
basement safeword trust trust trust
trust
safe word
you could argue that the new watching
the news isn't healthy
i mean you can feel yourself changing if
you watch something or go on social
media
right
this is no longer something that's just
a hypothesis it's obvious to everyone
take some time off the news or off
social media see if you don't feel
better you immediately will but as you
were during your monologue i was
thinking what is i am exhausted i am so
excited yeah not your show
funny have fun have a good time and i
thought i wonder if it's really trumped
arrangement we're we're sick of it's
just they are he's been gone
how long now years and they still have
this derangement where it's just going
and the anxiety and the the vitriol is
just it's just exhausting it's too much
you know what they have they have long
derangement yes yes
yes
right
won't go away
cat
sure
is it just me have you given up
no this is me trying
so what do you think you can can the
media be saved cnn is trying to change
they're trying to change we no we've
heard that they're trying to change have
there been changes i don't know because
i don't watch it yeah uh but i think
that uh like there's it's not really
news and that was the cnn's thing
forever is that we just do news and then
obviously that changed and so much of
what is called news now is just a guy
telling you what he thinks about stuff
right and like what you should think
about stuff and there's already an
oversaturation of that in the wilds so i
don't think we need that on tv also you
know i like to just watch like fun
things on tv
that's good yeah like forensic files yes
when people kill each other and bury
their loved ones yeah teen mom yeah teen
mom two teen mom young and pregnant um
young and pregnant um addicted and
pregnant it's really sad though and you
look them up on facebook ever after and
they're not doing well cyrus the worst
part about the news i think is that
i think cat kind of touches on it
everybody's kind of doing the same thing
right they're like they're they rip off
each other they just they travel in
packs
my teen is pregnant and so am i that's
what i forgot
she's like microwave popcorn near the
end yeah there might be another pop yeah
they're not really doing the same thing
and i have to defend cnn a little bit
here they they did bring in a news man
yeah so you know chris wallace is
getting a show
on the network
is called raising arizona oh that's
gonna be great he's gonna do
but but hey they're bringing in a news
guy so you know
they got that going for him
um they just
don't tell the news i think it's okay
to not have a lot of ratings if you're
just giving the news that's a good thing
if if you're being straight and telling
the news and people aren't tuning in
that means they're living their lives
and there's nothing to be paranoid about
but when your entire show is based off
of crying wolf or in this case crying
trump
which they already leaking like
he's going to announce he's running next
weekend so they're already leaking stuff
trying to give you a little tune in
so he would announce and why would he
announce now like it's it's a long time
away but they miss him so much yeah and
that's they just believe that don't
change too much we'll bring in wallace
i'll get everyone revved up and excited
and while everyone's revved up and
excited
then we can wait for trump to come back
he's gonna come back no one's ever been
revved up and excited by chris wallace
not even chris wallace
they love hysteria they love it walk it
in here cnn.com really walking down the
hall here the worst variant is here i
saw that and i know what this is yes
it's more infectious and much milder we
are doing that in the next segment i was
going to ask you about that because
their headline was the worst variant
it's the worst variant and here i
thought that was me
different kind of trust trust yeah trust
stay forward safe word
shannon
no one ever uses that word i like it
probably or for a reason maybe i don't
know don't get hr hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else